au final on n'est pas sur un effet whaou
on est sûrs en effet à ouais quand même
et c'est très impressionnant
[Musique]
huawei a encore frappé je crois que ça
pourrait que le type de ma vie
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être le titre de
ma vie au moment où en train de faire
cette vidéo je sais pas encore comment
je vais l'appeler
je pourrais très facilement l'appeler
huawei a encore frappé tellement le
titre est juste alors excusez moi
j'avais tellement hâte de vous parlez
pas fini tout un style dans le studio
ou alors ça pourrait s'appeler ou huawei
a récidivé l'éclairage bleu formidable
on y est
on parle aujourd'hui du pétrole trop le
patron pro qui est franchement une belle
promesse faite par huawei à la santé du
hellfest et de tous les festivaliers ça
fait un bien fou huawei a frappé fort
huawei a franchement continue à mettre
la barre hyper hot
alors je ne sais pas si vous avez suivi
si vous suivez l'actualité de whitehouse
intéresse oui non quoi comme en mai
dernier à huawei représenter à peu près
la même saison au mois de mars le p va
pro ensuite il ya eu le meilleur vin pro
et il ne produit rien aussi le p 20 il
ya eu aussi le pétain lie bon mais aussi
le made man et cette année ils ont fait
encore très très fort avec le p 30 pro
alors je me suis posé la question quand
le smartphone était présente et on
regarde un peu comme ça mais je vous en
êtes ma ma coque de protection
rhinochill lorsque vous le regardez
comme ça je me suis dit ouais il
ressemble beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup au p 20 pro est ce qu'au final
c'est pas un peu juste une version
améliorée du pépin pro est ce qu'on est
vraiment sur autre chose est ce que ce
smartphone apporte une haute valeur et
surtout est-ce que ce smartphone raconte
une autre histoire en fait l'histoire
elle n'est pas différente l'histoire
s'est sensiblement la même l'histoire
c'est une marque qui vous propose un
smartphone qui est vraiment topissime
pour la photographie c'est l'idée en
tout cas de la gamme p de huawei est là
très clairement avec le p 30 pro on
continue de monter on pourrait se dire
exactement de la même manière est ce que
au final est ce qu'il ya une vraie
grosse différence entre le paiement prog
était déjà énorme l'année dernière et le
paie 30 pro de cette année oui mais
c'est juste pour avoir des meilleure
photo meilleur en faible luminosité bon
voilà il fallait un petit peu l'effet
waouh et là ils ont fait un effet whaou
à incroyable avec son zoom zoom x 5
optique x 10 et bride et vous monter
jusqu'à un zoom x 50
alors vous me direz mais qu'est ce qu'on
va aller faire dans une fois 50
je suis d'accord avec vous
sur le papier on dit qu'est ce que je
vais peut-être dans une poêle 50 mais
lorsque vous le prenez en main lorsque
vous l'utilisez et que vous l'actionner
vous dites ah ouais quand même
et c'est vraiment tout ce que j'ai
entendu de toutes les personnes que j'ai
autour de moi qu'ils ont fait ah ouais
quand même
et c'est vraiment les faits ce
smartphone au final on n'est pas sûr en
effet où on est sûr en effet away quand
même et c'est très impressionnant
bon là j'enlève ma coque je fais un peu
le malin mais c'est vrai que dans
l'absolu préfère quand même le protéger
à tout simplement parce que un
smartphone comme ça avec le verre
voiliers qui est incurvé de ce côté là
j'ai peur de l'abîmer
ça c'est pas mal vous avez le choix soit
vous avez une coque qui est inclus
directement dans le packaging qui a une
coque transparente je voulais montrer
lorsque j'ai fait moins de boeing
le jour de la sortie du produit cette
coque transparente la signer directement
par huawei qui est fourni avec tue pas
mal elle est un peu soupe donc je suis
pas sûr que à terme soit celle qui vous
protège le mieux néanmoins elle a le
mérite de vous laisser voir le dos de
votre smartphone et de voir sous toutes
les coutures si maintenant vous voulez
vraiment profiter du dos de votre
smartphone ya un truc qui est pas mal du
tout c'est ça la c'est le crash garde de
rhinau shield et ce qui est cool c'est
qu'en fait ça vous le protège sur les
côtés vous pouvez le poser ça frotte pas
sur le dessous ça frotte pas sur le
dessus c'est pas mal alors après this
tombe sur un caillou un peu pointu bon
ben voilà il ya un moment il n'a pas non
plus être magique mais par contre comme
ça voyez vraiment profiter d'autres
smartphones c'est super sympa ça protège
donc ça c'est cool bon je l'enlève pour
la vidéo mais si ça vous intéresse je
compte pour moi je chéris nos chiffres
pour le p 30 il existe existent pour 4
en propre il ya plein de produits c'est
pour protéger vos écrans et quelque
chose chez rhinochill donc je vous
conseille d'aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil d'ailleurs assez franche peu tard
et cent fois smartphone c'est quasiment
qu'un écran petit banc au petit bord
vaillants petits manteaux existe mais
n'est pas très très gros sur le côté
c'est frank huston un effet de
profondeur qui est vraiment très jolie
ici aujourd'hui petite encoche goutte
d'eau mais surtout c'est vraiment très
très sympa regardez luminosité pousser à
fond c'est beau c'est chouette c'est un
smartphone qui est très lumineux même
lorsque blanc dans l'extase ça c'est
cool vous avez un écran oled de six
points 47 pouces de diagonale 2340 par
1080 pixels
nous avons grâce aux 19 points 5/9 stade
écran hd r c'est un écran de vraiment
bonne qualité j'adore ce que je vous
conseille c'est d'aller dans vos
paramètres d'affichage
vous allez dans mode est température de
couleur et vous mettez en couleurs
normal parce que les couleurs vives sap
est beaucoup trop je trouve que ça casse
un peu l'effet naturel
alors vous le verrez pas forcément tout
de suite parce que j'ai une colorimétrie
fait sur la vidéo dont on s'en rend pas
forcément compte mais croyez moi
le mode normal est vachement plus douce
et très sympa et là vous mettez en par
défaut parce que vous mettez show est
beaucoup trop jeune froid c'est beaucoup
trop bleu par défaut ça marche pour le
multimédia je trouve ça franchement
génial l'écran est vraiment cool on à la
petite goutte d'eau sur le côté c'est
une certitude s'est pas complètement
parfait il vous reste petit truc là
néanmoins c'est pas non plus
complètement déconnant ça reste très
discret et ce qui est cool en plus de ça
c'est l'audio pour garder pour le
multimédia
il ya du son qu'il ya beaucoup de fonds
c'est franchement une agréable sur ce
modèle vous avez un seul haut-parleur
qui situe là haut parleur mono vous
venez le cacher voyez il est qu ici on
pourrait se dire tiens aux rues pour
mettre un deuxième haut-parleurs là
c'est pas le cas ils n'ont pas fait on a
uniquement aux parlera par contre les
deuxièmes techno qui est assez
intéressante c'est un haut parleur situé
sous l'écran
la techno c'est l'acoustique display
technology en rouge vous avez un haut
parleur qui est placée sous l'écran
alors quand vous mettez face à vous vous
n'êtes pas du son qui vous arrive en
tête mais par contre ce cas c'est
intéressant je pense que ça vient
vraiment jouer pour les faits de graves
un peu de basses après au pouvoir
regarder qui ait pas deux prises jack
sur ce smartphone il y en a pas il y en
a une sur le pétrole soit p30 pro c'est
pas possible je pense que d'un point de
vue purement techno c'était compliqué de
pouvoir passer une prise jack donc du
coup il y en a pas je pas si vous avez
suivi le jour j'anime et un live sur la
page facebook de muntari com
et justement j'ai posé la question à
françois de chez huawei honor françois
il y en a pas pourquoi comment est ce
qui m'a répondu c'était très juste c'est
être fait de dire en fait avant j'en
avais pas du tout on en a rajouté sur le
pet rentrer c'était possible sur le
pétrole trop priori c'est pas possible
mais bon moi je suis toujours un peu
partie des gens qui disent pas c'est
dommage j'aime bien ma prise jack je me
suis fait avoir un casque bluetooth mais
c'est vrai que le coût de la prise jack
j'aime bien même si c'est vrai que
j'utilise de moins en moins d'ailleurs
je sais pas si c'est votre cas dites moi
vous tu te poses 30 secondes
est-ce que vous utilisez les prises jack
sur les smartphones est ce que le fait
qu'un smartphone puisse avoir une prise
jack
ça peut vous décider à acheter tel ou
tel produit est ce que vous utilisez un
smartphone avec une prise jack
oui non pas comment vous marquez tous en
bas je très curieux devant les résultats
parce que moi j'ai eu beaucoup utiliser
un casque le mdr 75,06 de sonic et un
moniteur de studio et aujourd'hui j'ai
passé vraiment
sur le whc blixen 3 toujours de sonic
castéra l'émission de bruit que
j'utilise bien évidemment en bluetooth
en plus je sais pas si vous avez vu il
ya un truc qui est assez marrant sur ce
smartphone c'est qui les place sur le
dessus et en dessous ce qui fait qu'on
peut le faire tenir à la verticale donc
ça c'est assez marrant on peut s'y
amuser on peut prendre son smartphone on
peut le mettre à l'envers on peut le
faire tenir comme on veut ça c'est cool
sur la tête sur les fesses on fait comme
on veut et votre smartphone vous devez
retenir est la verticale ça peut être
intéressant pour certaines photos si
vous voulez vraiment l'hyper stabiliser
sinon moi de mon côté si j'ai besoin
j'utilise ce petit trépied de joby qui
marche très bien et qui fait très bien
la faire ça vous permet également de
tenir facilement avec votre doigt ça
c'est assez cool bon design assez sympa
rentrée moi ce que j'aime beaucoup aussi
c'est donc puisqu'en raison design c'est
le triple module photo que vous avez ici
c'est très bien intégré avec la petite
caméra time of light et puis surtout le
fait d'avoir se dégrader alors il ya
plusieurs couleurs mais ces couleurs là
elles sont juste magnifique un excellent
boulot qui a été fait de la part de nous
envoyer là dessus moi j'adore vraiment
fan le vert je trouve ça chouette
après attention sont des produits
toujours un peu glissant dont je vous le
redis une fois de plus mettez une coque
de protection pour être sûr qu'ils ne
glissent pas et que vous ne les chapier
pas vous l'utiliser comme une petite
télécommande grâce à un farouche qui
hélas assez aussi cool que ça existe
l'esthétisme c'est bien beau c'est le
cas de le dire après la question c'est
qu'est ce qu'il a sous le moteur qu est
ce qu a sous le capot
et de ce point de vue là il des mérite
absolument pas on sait tous vont envoyer
fabrique des smartphones performants ils
ont déjà montré à maintes reprises mais
là il continue continue à progresser ils
ont leur pierrine 980 qui marche
hyper bien couplé à 8 gigas de ram en
tout cas les choses qu'il faut 128 go de
stockage
la plus petite config 256 ou 512 giga
tous aspects un smartphone qui est pas
cadeau cadeaux que coûte un peu moins de
1000 euros dans sa config de base et
après des coups montés forcément ça vous
coûte un peu plus cher mais ça va que je
tombe vous je le mets qu'il fait du surf
en même temps c'est vrai que vous aurez
pour votre argent
et ça c'est hyper hyper cool
personnellement ça fait plusieurs jours
que j'utilise
il ne chauffe pas il est toujours
performant il répond très rapidement et
en plus ce qui est top c'est la partie
autonomic vous avez une grosse batterie
de 4200 millions paire eur l'idée c'est
que smartphone il gardé pendant deux
jours
et si vous avez oublié leurs charges et
le matin vous retrouver à 10 15% de
batterie vous le branchez et en trois
minutes vous l'avait chargé à 1 70 % 5
points qui est extrêmement positif parce
que aujourd'hui
il y à des smartphones qui garde qui ont
belle autonomie mais si vous avez oublié
de charger et bien il faut quand même
prévoir un petit peu de temps pour
recharger et il faut pas être pris au
dépourvu
avec lui vous avez aucun problème vous
trouvez une petite présence un coin mais
un quart d'heure voudront chez vous
repartez vous êtes tranquille et ça
sécurise vachement en plus et se
recharge en usb type c'est ça vous vous
en douterez il ya un chargeur 40 watts
c'est lui qui me permet de recharger
très rapidement vous pouvez aussi le
recharger sans fil en 15 watts
ça ira moins vite mais c'est pratique et
autre point très intéressant qui arrivé
l'année dernière avec le mec d'un procès
la recharge inversée votre smartphone
est chargé à fond vos petits écouteurs
vos meubles ce que vous voulez vous
n'avez pas assez de jus vous prenez
votre smartphone vous transférez du jus
de votre smartphone à ce que vous voulez
ou pourquoi pas aux smartphones aux
copains en face c'est permet de le
recharger
c'est vachement intéressant il ya un
truc qui va choix intéressant c'est le
capteur d'empreintes digitales pour
venir le déverrouiller alors on connaît
le 14 empreintes digitales qui est
placée sous l'écran c'est un tout qui
date de l'année dernière phase et une
techno qui se développent et je me suis
dit ciao huawei nous a pas mis de
capteur d'empreintes digitales
ultrasonique est-ce que ça va marcher
vitesse que ça va être bien parce que le
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui n'est
pas ultrasonique c'est pas le plus
rapide du monde
et là je suis franchement hyper surpris
vous poser à peine votre doigt sa
déverrouille directement et vous n'êtes
pas obligé de laisser appuyez vous
mettez un peu en contact ça déverrouille
très rapidement et ça croyez moi c'est
cool parce que c'est pas le cas de tous
les smartphones là vous avez un truc qui
est vraiment très rapide c'est génial il
a également failli sonore qui marche
très bien ça va vite c'est pratique
enfin et pas mal de solutions pour
débrouiller après l' os est une histoire
de goût vous avez eu et mu 9 points qui
tourne sur un android 9 paille
on aime ou on n'aime pas il n'y a pas
des tiroirs d'applications vous avez
toutes vos applis qui sont là il ya des
patients qui critiqueront qui n'aimeront
pas il y en a qui aimeraient ça c'est
très personnel c'est difficile de se
prononcer là dessus ce qui est assez
cool c'est la navigation par gestes le
fait que vous ayez également dans vos
paramètres pas mal de petites options et
notamment l' équilibre digital que vous
retrouvez ici pour savoir comment vous
avez utilisé votre smartphone
aujourd'hui votants d'écran ça c'est
bien ça se développe de plus en plus on
trouve aujourd'hui sur pas tous les
smartphones mais quasiment et c'est
vraiment bien se sont intégrés
maintenant la crau
question qui se pose c'est la question
de la partie photo vidéo avant de vous
montrer directement les clichés que j'ai
pu prendre on va refaire un petit tour
du côté de l'appareil photo pour qu'on
comprenne bien vous avez donc trois
capteurs de ce côté-là et un petit
capteur là parmi les 3 capteurs vous
avez un capteur principal qui est 40
n'est qu'un pixel ouverture de f
1.6 stabilisation optique et logiciels
c'est un capteur or y/y b je vous la
fais très courte avant ce soit pénible
normalement lorsque vous avez des
capteurs photo vous avez un capteur
rouge bleu vert et là vous avez un
capteur rouge jaune jaune bleu pas de
verre le fait d'avoir remplacé le vert
par le jaune ça permet de laisser passer
plus de lumière et ça c'est en je dirais
en tout cas un des gros points forts en
photo du jeu p 30 pro par rapport au p
20 pro vous avez également un deuxième
capteur qui est un zoom zoom x 5 8
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
3.4 qui ne va pas être excellent pour la
photo de nuit tout simplement parce que
l'ouverture n'est pas assez grande il ne
sera pas entrée assez de lumière
il sera bon par contre pour toutes les
photos pour les zooms vous allez voir
c'est un zoom périscopique qui me
permettra d'avoir un x 5 optique x 10
l'hybride il x 50 digital vous
complètement stabilisée enfin l'espagne
en 105
vous allez voir c'est hyper bluffant et
vous avez également un ultra grand-angle
de 20 mégapixels qui ouvre à 2.4 et ici
sur le côté à lui tout petit c'est la
caméra tu of time of light c'est le
temps de vol qui va vous servir pour la
profondeur de champ en fait votre caméra
tough faut l'imaginer comme un sonar
bateau il y avait de la lumière la
lumière va s'infléchir va revenir
jusqu'à lui ça lui permettra de mesurer
la profondeur
ça c'est intéressant pour plusieurs cas
de figure déjà pour du jeu lorsque vous
allez jouer la caméra tough connaîtra
votre position vos mouvements et avec un
petit dock sur lequel vous allez poser
votre paie 30 pro les pouvoir jouer à
différents jeux faire du ski faire ce
que vous voulez ça je voulais déjà
montré en exemple très concret dans ma
vidéo de présentation du pétrole pro la
semaine dernière à paris donc ça c'est
marrant le deuxième point qui est hyper
intéressant c'est pour elle le mode
portrait puisque la caméra est capable
de réellement connaître la distance
donc en gros la profondeur il va
appliquer un vrai flou par rapport à la
profondeur et pas uniquement un flou
stimulée par rapport à une découpe
logiciel donc ça c'est intéressant et ça
fait aussi un peu la différence alors un
peu pas complètement je vais vous
montrer sur des photos que j'ai prises
moi je joue toujours un peu les pistes
ainsi l'eau mais devant un fond un peu
blanc avec les cheveux comme ça un peu
grisonnants des fois un peu compliqué
mais vous allez voir le résultat est
franchement hyper cool alors à commencer
par ce qu'alan petitesse de ce zoom x 50
parce que pour moi c'est vraiment les
faits qui est complètement incroyable là
dessus regardez on va prendre on est là
on va commencer à zoomer alors on est
sur un x 1 on est sur x 5 déjà gagné sur
le x 5 déjà voyant fois 500 ont fait une
qualité qui est juste complètement ouf
ici et là on va venir chercher des
choses un peu plus en arrière là je sais
pas si vous vous rendez compte
mais regardez bien ce qu'on est en train
de voir la la ça correspond à salah à ce
que vous avez ici vous des vins vaudois
qui passe devant
ça c'est ça et ça c'est le zoom x 50 et
ça c'est vraiment très très très
impressionnant parce que si vous
regardez comme ça c'est pas possible
même avec roger h5 et je vais venir
zoomez alors j'ai pas un tel objectif
mais voyez à distance je suis sur un 12
60 les cas sûrement gh5 mais le truc
lorsqu'on revient là c'est juste à lui
si non et ça pour moi c'est vraiment le
gros gros gros gros gros effet whaou 2
ce smartphone bien évidemment l'idée
c'était d'aller faire de l'espionnage
chez vos voisins avec vos deux fois 50
en bout cassant drian balustrade mais
vraiment vous allez pouvoir redécouvrir
les choses sous un autre angle
je vous montre quelques photos que j'ai
prises à paris le joug vous allez voir
le truc est juste incroyable
ça c'est une image que je vous ai montré
l'autre jour à la présentation lorsqu'on
était à paris voyez la personne qui est
là bas derrière cette dame là eh bien on
la retrouve ici vous voyez ici
vous reconnaîtrez bien évidemment je
vais passer et voyez lorsque je dis
résout mais avec mon zoom x 50 voiliers
alors c'est pas parfait c'est la nuit
mais c'est hallucinant ce qu'on est
capable de capter c'est dans des
conditions de nuit donc forcément c'est
pas terrible mais c'est assez incroyable
et ça montre vraiment qu'on peut faire
avec ce smartphone autres photos qui m'a
complètement bluffé vous devinerez au
fond l'arc de triomphe on est sur les
champs-elysées je me suis mis en plein
milieu vous en douterez vous êtes prêts
c'est vraiment bluffant
tout en haut l'arc de triomphe alors moi
je bouge donc forcément j'ai un peu la
tremblote donc l'image est pas parfaite
mais si vous arrivez à stabiliser votre
smartphone c'est juste ou fissiles
c'est incroyable et rappelez vous qu on
est à cette distance je montre autre
chose ça c'est pareil on est sur une
photo la nuit commence à tomber donc bon
c'est pas complètement idéal on est sur
les changes sur le roof top là en face
la voyez il ya une espèce de petite
cabane on sait pas trop ce que c'est eh
bien on va pas faire de l'espionnage
vont pas les voir chez les gens donc
c'était tous des bureaux donc c'est pour
ça que je me suis permis d'aller voir là
vous
votre cabane ok c'est pas mal ah ouais
ça a l'air intéressant aller 11 ou
encore plus je voyais le truc c'est ouf
alors là par contre il commence à faire
nuit donc on n'a pas en détail de ouf
mais c'est impressionnant qu'on peut
sortir avec et en plus ce qui est
vraiment impressionnant lorsque vous
faites ça c'est vous prenez je le mets
aller en toutefois 50
alors moi je tremble j'en ai déjà parlé
si vous suivez vous le savez on va
essayer de se caler sur un truc il ya
une stabilisation qui ouvre avec un zoom
x 50 que vous réussissiez à avoir ça
avec un mec un tremblement essentiel
croyez moi c'est vraiment une prouesse
technologique quelqu'un qui ne tremble
absolument pas ils eurent un truc qui
est hyper stabiliser pour chuter ce que
vous voulez dans des bonnes conditions
le résultat est juste incroyable et
c'est là toute la force de huawei
aujourd'hui c'est tout le boulot qui
fait derrière recherche et développement
vous avez des ingénieurs qui bossent
comme des fous pour vous trouver des
technologies hallucinante et c'est la
vraie force de frappe de cette marque
parce que huawei il ya dix ans en france
personne connaissent et il ya quelques
années en france moins de dix ans les
gens qui connaissaient pas encore en
très peu de temps ils ont une
progression qui est hallucinant pour
vous sortir ça là avec le zoom
périscopique ces cas vraiment un énorme
travail qui est fait derrière et on
continue dans les photos la colorimétrie
je la trouve assez juste pas trop saturé
il ya un beau piqué beaux détails
cavaliers bon on est sur 10 de son
pellegrino mais je peux venir zoomer et
là je me retrouve sur un truc qui a dû
détails sur un truc qui est nette
alors que vous voyez je t'aime une
petite distance je peux venir chercher
dans l'image
je garde de la qualité ça c'est
franchement cool et ce qu'il faut savoir
sur le capteur principal vous avez 1,40
mégapixels mais par des fossés paramétré
en 10 mégapixels ce qui vous permet de
venir
zoom et de venir récupérer du détail
comme ça et en photos de nuit d'avoir
des photos beaucoup plus lumineuse parce
que ça vaut revenir au 4xl en un vous
utilisez 4 pixels des 40 mégapixels pour
vous sortir un seul et même gros pixels
vous avez du détail vous avez un truc
qui évoqué chouette et ça c'est
franchement intéressant ça c'est une
photo nue alors la photo de miss assez
intéressant qu'il ya un excellent
travail logiciels qui est fait derrière
de la part de huawei vous avez vraiment
la matière là vous êtes bien le détail
au niveau des pavés et là on avait très
peu de lumière sur ces jolies ravioles
regarder je peux venir zoomer dessus
c'est franchement pas mal on retrouve
bien le détail ici les affaires de la
macro si ça c'est intéressant vous
pouvez vous rapprocher jusqu'à 2.5 cm
regardez c'est un peu gras mais c'était
très bon
soupe sympathique regardez moi là je
rendu ennui c'est vraiment hyper
impressionnant quartier de l'horloge
c'est pareil c'est chouette j'ai un beau
rendu lien super bien fait nos logiciels
saas et la station de métro arts et
métiers je serais très très chouette
automne nuit-là très sympa on a le plus
petit mac do de france je ne suis pas
regarder la qui est planqué ici alors on
s'en fiche du mcdo mais c'est plus en
détails et en utilisant avec le zoom x
55 en arrive là vous vous rendez compte
que ça là c'est ici là et là que zoug 3
là on est la nuit les conditions sont
optimales vous rendez compte quand même
ce qu'on arrive à capter ces tout-petits
ici c'est vraiment très impressionnant
de nuit également le rendu est juste
hallucinant entrepôt qui est intéressant
c'est le mode portrait le détourage est
assez net mars plutôt bien grâce à la
caméra tough le détourage et franchement
plutôt bien fait là il se perd
légèrement on dirait sur le coin de mes
cheveux mais bon c'est du point de
détail il apparaît qu'il a bien repéré
les petits cheveux sur le côté haima
légèrement de manger les petits côtés
mais bon c'est pas dans l'absolu c'est
pas à lui sinon je trouve quand même que
le boulot est vraiment bien faire à des
est complètement flou là entre mes
doigts comment il ya un vrai beau boulot
qui est fait traitement logiciel et la
même chose en extérieur regardez-la
détourage entre les doigts et parfait on
dirait qu'un petit flou de bougé avoir
peut-être bon on a bien les petits
cheveux derrière qui sont pas
complètement floutés concernant la
partie grand-angle c'est pas mal mais
c'est pas à lui sinon c'est bien lorsque
vous avez beaucoup lumière si vous
n'avez pas beaucoup de lumière c'est pas
terrible photo prise avec l'objectif de
40 mégapixels et la halle et luttera
grand-angle de 20 mégapixels voit tout
de suite la la c'est assez clair hélas
ne fait plus foncée les couleurs sont
pas exactement les mêmes bonnes choses
ici
ça c'est le capteur normal tu seras
grand angle voyez on capte beaucoup
moins lumière il est vraiment pas
optimisé pour les photos de nuit
vous avez donc un combo qui est
énormissime quatre capteurs kirin 980 de
l'intelligence artificielle ça vous
optimise toutes vos photos
c'est facile c'est transparent c'est
cool et l avant vous avez une caméra de
celle fille de 30 2 mégapixels qui fait
le job qui vous sortira des photos
correctes et keira très bien côté vidéo
je trouve aussi vraiment excellent la
stabilisation est hyper cool
le rendu est vraiment de bonne qualité
il ya une belle progression les
dernières j'étais moins fan sur le p 20
pro je trouvais que bron s'éteint
excellent photophone mais sur la vidéo
c'est un peu moins sarlat je trouve pas
reconquis une belle évolution fait part
d'un web sur le côté vidéo sur la
stabilisation sur l'express le général
est là dessus aussi pareil très belle
progression de l'apport de huawei c'est
un smartphone qui peut accueillir une
double carte sim que vous trouvez ici
dos à dos il a dû fc bien évidemment
pour le paiement dématérialisé mais
aussi pour moi ouais cheikh samba
paralysée quelques jours sur un tel
ordinateur de huawei il a du bluetooth
5.0 bon pour vous connecter avec votre
casque à réduction de bruit si vous
voulez écouter de la musique au casque
il est équipé 68 mais par contre il
n'est pas compatible 5 g de notre côté
la 5g pour l'instant on la trouve pas
partout
la 5g arrivera plus tard on en reparlera
deuxième semestre 2010 9
donc on a le temps en tout cas moi je
trouve vraiment très intéressant
aujourd'hui je le verrai un défaut qui
est un défaut qui vient effectivement de
son adn comme vous avez un écran incurvé
vous allez souvent laissé traîner un
bout de doigt ou quelque chose pour
tenir son côté et c'est souvent
interprété comme un mouvement c'est pas
bien grave c'est du point de détail ça
arrive de temps en temps une fois de
plus je vous le dit mettez une coque et
avec une coque ce problème est
complètement effacés
pour ma part je remets ma coque pas et
comme ça voyez je le tiens le problème
n'est plus à du tout vous l'aurez
suppose compris j'aime beaucoup la
proposition que des fêtes paraguay cette
année où c'est vraiment intéressant et
continue à monter en gamme continue à
nous surprendre
aller plus loin en termes de photos
aller plus loin en terme de vidéo aller
toujours plus loin en termes de qualité
de smartphones ça c'est vraiment hyper
intéressant et c'est là où on voit toute
la force de la recherche et
développement d'une marque est capable
d'innover comme ça tous les six mois
tous les ans sur la photo c'est juste ou
festives je sais pas vous ce que vous en
pensez
comment vous le trouvez se paie 30 pro
est ce qu'il vous plaît
oui non quoi comment quelles sont pour
vous les points forts qui font vraiment
la réussite de ce produit quels sont les
points faibles
est-ce que vous pensez que le fait
d'avoir un zoom x 50 ça a un sens oui
non est ce que vous voyez des cas
d'usagé
qu'est ce que vous pensez du zoom
optique x 5 zones hybride x 10 mark et
moi tout ça et quelle est selon vous la
personnalité la plus importante pour ce
smartphone
celle qui pourrait en tout cas vous
permettre vous d'aller l'acheter vous
marrer tout ça bien évidemment aux
commentaires vous invite à rester
connectés parce que on va continuer à
les voir plein de produits du moment des
smartphones offre il ya plein plein
plein plein de produits perdre où l'on
va parler d'un ordinateur dans quelques
jours de huawei sont dit pas plus pour
l'instant on en reparle
ensemble merci à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo vous avez les playlists qui
sont juste là pour aller voir tous les
autres produits du moment et je vous
souhaite des tressages prenez soin ou et
je voudrais le gros becs à bientôt
tchaourou
[Musique]